je m'appelle roubaud ceci est mon
histoire
bienvenue sur le doublage de coubon je
m'appelle killian je fais la voirie
2 qui joue de ce band jour il peut
réaliser des origamis sur la façon de
petits jouent une espèce de cranach il
est débrouillard il est courageux
la magie de ta mère et est extrêmement
puissante mais parfois il a des petits
moments de fabien il a un peu les
chocottes compterait pas sa mère on fait
quoi alors nous devons retrouver
l'armure elle seule assurer une
productif et puis il va vivre une épopée
suivez moi c'est peut-être un piège nom
de toucher à rien c'est lui il ya de la
magie des samouraïs et des cons
et d'aventurés fantastiques plaquette
est désormais magath c'est vraiment très
poétique donne une fin heureuse à ton
histoire ça super jolies filles